i'm here in the kitchen with
mother-daughter dream team laverne
richardson aka mama laverne and donna
richardson and they are making their
world famous chicken and waffles which
now you can get at home
pre-seasoned amazing mama laverne what's
next we finished our chicken and now
we're gonna have mama laverne's light
and fluffy waffles i like that
description
i love the description and what is the
foolproof like
what's your secret yeah my secret is
you're gonna use your melted butter
buttermilk
buttermilk and the egg yolk and then add
it into my
special secret tell us what it is
tell us what it is and after you stir
the liquid into that flour mix the key
to my buttermilk waffles is to take that
egg white yes beat it stiffen the egg
white yeah and then fold it into that
mom you told our secret
[Laughter]
you got some light and fluffy waffles
yes let's see
i love folding in an eggplant yes it
makes it huge
and then you can use the batter um for
pancakes and you can also give it a nice
arm workout
whipping that egg white see oh it's got
a little bit more just a little bit more
but we can go ahead and take okay can we
say that yeah and i was gonna share with
you
um so that you could try mine are you
gonna put something on the bottom
you want that one here oh i gotta get
syrup on sarah yes here we go whatever
you like oh my god
i will chair we'll share it okay and my
mom i'm telling you she's perfected this
recipe because you know chicken and
waffles started
have you tried let's try this
this is my mock chicken this is the corn
chicken
so if you don't eat regular chicken this
is excellent isn't it so good oh my god
you can do this with cauliflower other
vegetables this is heaven but the batter
is so good how have you gone into those
chicken breasts and they come so juicy
oh my god my mom this is chicken and
waffles is like love on your plate and
joy in your belly that's what it's like
you
know
oh wait
no no
i'm not ready mama laverne and donna
where can you get this fabulous mix you
can buy it on amazon and shop right
grocery stores thanks to jeff and sandy
brown they gave us our first opportunity
to be in grocery stores i think they're
smart they are so we're so grateful to
them and our pastor my favorite day is
sunday i go to church and then i go to
brunch and now the place that i was
going to branch out for all these years
they are now featuring mama laverne's
chicken and waffles on their menu
[Applause]
whenever you guys go to dallas it's
called albert
will you show me what it looks like when
you're cooking and dancing and dancing
okay and cooking and cooking and then
while you're taking that break
then mama laverne just gone dip it down
is
[Music]